for defending our democracy as we vote
to send the freedom to vote
john lewis voting
uh
john lewis act to the senate for urgent
consideration
i just want to say four things about the
gift of the freedom to vote bill we
passed it twice in a house under
different means
same thing that the john lewis bill
passed it twice in the house so now
today we're sending it over with the
prospect uh that it will have
consideration in the senate four things
people should know about it
four reasons why members should be
voting for it and we have a vote on them
now so i'm gonna have to
go dabble that down
four things are one
it stops partisan redistricting
very popular with the american people by
making sure we honor the constitution
the voting rights act
act and the uh
community of interest ends partisan
redistricting two it stops voter
suppression and the nullification of
elections you know the story over 400
bills introduced across the country 30
some of them already enacted in law
which not only suppress the vote
particularly among people of color but
also
but also
nullify elections
people have voted we'll decide how
that turns out nullifying elections
third it's it insists on disclosure of
big dark special interest money which
suffocates the airway which is a form of
voter suppression and misrepresentations
that they put forth they're constantly
supreme court has said they can get as
much money as they want but we're saying
they must disclose
they must disclose transparency
and forth to amplified voices of small
donors and the grassroots
and no taxpayer dollars used to do that
stop partisan redistricting
stop the suppression of the vote
nullification of elections
it stopped big dark money from having
such an impact on our political process
and honor the grassroots participation
in addition to that
in terms of the job that was part of the
bill
every republican president has and since
nixon ford reagan president george
washington and president george stevie
bush
george w bush signed the most recent
voting rights act a bill that passed the
congress like 390 in the house almost
unanimously in the senate
not that long ago
had always been bipartisan
until now
and so
passing that bill would be very very
important for voting rights in our
country so fundamental to our democracy
so i'm excited about today
that we've received this
uh we're sending this over to the senate
receiving uh some optimism that that
the focus will be on and hopefully the
success will be there especially in time
for martin luther king day
again i i just want to commend
terry sewell mr butterfield jim mcgovern
jerry nadler
zoe longfriends are laughing they're
laughing so many times her committee
doesn't even have a christmas or
hanukkah or any
uh holiday
uh so many people
john sarbanes has been the patron saint
of this
for or the godfather whatever analogy
you want to make of this legislation so
i want to thank all of them for giving
us this special special opportunity
earlier this week we passed the gi bill
to protect our democracy again house
democrats worked it's really important
to know about that and said this on the
floor the other day but in case you
weren't paying strict attention
when we had the first gi bill
it was the fruit of the
advocacy and labor of the american
legion and other groups following world
war one
they were not treated as fairly as they
should have been and they wanted future
veterans to be treated better hence the
gi bill
president roosevelt signed a bill and
made great statements about how we owe
so much to our veterans we we all know
that
listening to the veterans that bill came
forth with education with housing and
all
home ownership in the rest
we continue to listen to our veterans
when we had the
post-911 gi bill which enabled even
expanded the benefit for education not
only to our vets
but also to their family members and
even if they died in action still the
benefits survive for their families was
very very important
and now we're listening to our veterans
who are telling us that we really need
to have
expand and strengthen the gi bill
eligibility for reservists and guardsmen
and so uh so that's what we did earlier
this week in the house i hope it will
pass the senate as you see today let's
take me to the next subject of clovid
that the president is enlisting
some of that
talent and
those resources
uh in the fight against cover
as we work for the people the virus
colonial virus still is a very top
priority
we know the science tells us vaccines
masks
testing testing testing spacing and the
rest uh our path to
ridding ourselves of that
and when it comes to our schools
as a grandmother of a public school
student
i'm very hopeful that we can have
children safely in school to the
greatest extent possible
masking and testing separation vaccines
help us to do that
and uh i'm glad that the president has
this initiative now for 500 million
tests uh to be sent out and then with
the prospect of another 500 million
tests so that
people aren't know that they're
surrounded by safe people
it's always sad to see the numbers
800 nearly 850 000 americans already
gotta resend our prayers and our prayers
that they and their families are in our
hearts
our prayers
and
yesterday we had as his final public
uh
resting event a
harry reid lying in state in the united
states capital so appropriate for
someone who did so much to make the
future better for america
the comments that were said there the
show of support for him the president of
the united states the vice president
members of cabinet bipartisan members of
congress coming to pay their respects to
this great patriot
those of us who were at his funeral
services celebration of life
in nevada
to
hear two presidents president biden and
former president obama
making their remarks was quite
remarkable
but to hear
harry's children talk about him with
something just glorious to behold we
would all hope that our children could
even come anywhere in the same category
of uh
um
reflection about us as harry reid's
children did it was so so beautiful now
they took him home last night in nevada
state that he loved worked for always
looked out for in every way as i said
not only that environmental
uh climate by protecting the beautiful
patron
natural patrimony of environment but
also the political climate by protecting
their status in the presidential
election
um
process
he will always be remembered for his
goodness it was about family he was a
person of great state
and he cared about the future we were
missing
and so we talked about royal rights gi
bill cobain harry reid any questions
thank you thank you madam speaker leader
mccarthy says he will not comply with
the january 6th select committee does he
have an obligation to cooperate and
should he be subpoenaed if he refuses to
continue
i think he has an obligation as we seek
the truth to
help with that but up to the committee
as to what they do next i i um i
use it
they make their decisions they come
forward and i'm not
prepared to say what they do next but
they'll be telling us
he's problematic for the investigation
if all house republicans just refuse to
talk
the truth we will find the truth and the
committee will use
of that if they have said everything is
on the table at one point
in order to do that i have confidence in
the
bipartisan nature of the committee
uh they
are working very hard as we can see in
the public domain with the product of
their work and i have confidence
a couple of years ago when there were
questions about
congress for trump administration
officials you even referred to the
i mean this is a particular issue for
congress if you have numbers who are
uncooperative it's hard to get them with
subpoenas therefore if they were going
to take any sort of extraordinary stuff
one of the things that would follow the
committee but it could also go to you to
sign off on some particular you know
discipline or ethics committee or
whatever you would decide to do it and
dealing with a member of congress
particularly the minority leader well i
have as one who has served on the ethics
committee for many years longer than
anybody else i've always said any issues
about the ethics committee referring
things should not
come out of the leaders with the
speaker's office that's up to the
process to uh to put forth and uh and
also now people can bring in charge from
outside because we establish the outside
uh entity supreme uh bring something
forward to the ethics committee but i
have no intention of interfering with
the work of the committee
that's absolutely not they they have
their data they have their uh their
testimony that they're taking they know
the path that they want i don't i defer
to their judgment yes sir madam speaker
you said you say today sets up a
prospect for consideration of the new
voting rights laws just doesn't seem to
be a prospect for actual passage
what's changing where is this going well
you have to go over and ask that in the
senate uh but we do believe that the
what we called for the people act and
now called the freedom to vote act is a
bill that very much had
the uh input of senator manchin
as a former governor as a former
secretary of state he did great things
in his state to again
stop big dark money from having an
impact
on elections he has a there's a voter id
rule that they have there
that has been incorporated into this so
he knows the subject and this bill is a
reflection of some of his input and
hopefully he won't defend his bill in
terms of having it brought to the foot
but it's no use wasting your time asking
me questions about what the senate will
do you just have to go ask them what
their next path is
but it is
really important for the american people
to know
because what is stunning is to see the
misrepresentations
that are made for example on the floor
of the house
now i mean i'm going to go into them
because i don't want to return to their
misrepresentations but the facts are as
i said
partisan redistricting
and that
big dark money dominating politics and
that
suppressing the vote and nullifying
elections and that
supporting the grassroots
for that and then as i say the voting
rights which has not been partisan
before in recent history
and now
has become so in terms of the process in
the senate but we are excited because we
passed these bills again and again in
two different congresses
and as recently as last year in this
congress and that they're
we had to do them again because we're in
a new congress we also had to do the
voting rights act with a fresh array of
hearings around the country because of
violations that the republicans
committed in the
2020 election were so blatant that it
established another level
of uh
documentation for the need of the voting
rights
sorry
as far as the voting rights bill is
concerned um we heard what the president
said um
in his speech and
it appeared that there was criticism uh
from the upper chamber from uh mr durbin
saying that he went
a little bit over the top a little bit
uh what are your thoughts on that
and do you think that the president may
have gone a little bit too far in trying
to sell this particular bill to the
american people and trying to get votes
to try and get this passed by the
filibuster now i stand with the
president i think that i
thought his speech was wonderful and i
stand with him in the fight for voting
rights uh i
no criticism of mr durbin he has to do
what he has to do in terms of his own
members and the rest
the only christian would make two i
wouldn't say their criticism but
observations nobody knows who will
counter it and if we're making the case
if they want to be with
a mark martin the king of bull connor
who's that maybe with martin luther king
or the martin luther king and john lewis
for the people who unleash the fierce
dogs on them that's who will connor is
strong thurman
none of us have a lot of happy memories
about them so again since you asked my
critique of the president speak uh i i
thought it was fabulous i come out
congratulate him for it was well
received even among those who have had
some apprehension of of uh
what's going to happen with this all of
this next so i thank him for it and i
stand with the president in the fight
for voting rights
to vote for the bill as well as again
[Music]